Welcome to Blind Spot.
Actually, let's make that PUBG Blind Spot.
It's a 5v5 PvP game from a top-down view.
But watch your step.
Into the darkness lies the blind spot.
You can't see them, but they can see you.
Danger is literally around every spot.
Plant the bomb, defend the site.
Haven't I played this a million times before?
Well, hold that thought, because this is where we change the
rules.
Pick a route and let's break in.
Wait, hold up.
Keep it down.
Use your elbow.
Slip in quietly.
Watch every blind spot.
Shields up the front.
Use everything you've got.
Maybe Red Chip Amplifier this time.
Stealth mode.
Ambush.
Or flashbang.
Breaching hook.
Blue chip detector.
Ambush.
Wait.
What if they're waiting to ambush us?
As long as we've got your back, you'll clear that path
eventually.
Alright, here we are at the crypt site.
Man, look at that defense.
Let's bust these barricades open.
It's your showtime.
Smash it.
Blow it up.
Everything.
Time to plant the decryptor.
But heads up, this is their last stand.
And they won't go down easily.
Pop smoke and blind the defense.
Still too many hostiles?
Screw it.
Just force your way in and tank it with the shield.
Now, planting is the ideal way to win, sure.
But...
And you're the last one standing?
Then lock in.
It's time to make a highlight reel.
Double kill.
Triple kill.
Quadra kill.
Clutch.
Every angle counts.
PUBG Blindspot.
Yo!
Before I begin, I will have to mention a huge shout out and
thank you to PUBG Blindspot for today's sponsor!
sponsored this entire tournament so huge thank you to them
if you guys want to support this stream this tournament and
pubg blind spot please feel free to click on the link pinned
in the chat and either twitch or youtube um and or in the
description on youtube it really does help out a lot wow i
have to make the disclaimer first so that you guys know we
are sponsored here so what brings me here today a very rare
multi-stream day where both timmy and yemi are back again
and i hope you two will play nice all right you two up there
on the top right i see you two up there you guys better
treat each other well you two are brothers better treat each
other well guys uh yeah ambush the donkey bird ambush all
right so the reason why we are doing a multi-stream is the
because the tournament's up on february 15th and 16 today's
not the tournament by the way Just a little disclaimer, a
little reminder, guys, today is not the tournament.
It's actually next week on February 15th to 16th.
Today is just the announcement of the tournament.
So I'm going to give you guys the details, what the
tournament structure is going to be like.
Who's going to be playing here, playing in my tournament?
There will be four teams.
You guys all see the, saw the captains, they got announced
already earlier this week.
But we'll finally know who are their teammates today.
But yes, like I said, the tournament itself will be a
multi-stream as well.
So for those who are at Twitch, you guys, Timmy, the Timmy's
over there, they will get the full casting and broadcast of
the tournament itself.
So the multiple team POVs, the match POVs, the casting, the
interviews, that's what the Timmy's are going to get.
The Yimmys over here on YouTube, you guys are going to get
the individual POVs.
um of my channel so of like my pov of like how my gameplay
is gonna be like um and you know my pov of the entire
tournament itself so that's what youtube's gonna get and
that's what twitch is gonna get so you guys will have to
watch both streams to get both sides of whatever is going on
i almost swore there but i have to make remember i am
sponsored today i was like whatever the is going
my twitch channel will have the full casting production side
of the entire tournament while on youtube i will have my pov
with my team and that is why we're gonna be multi-streaming
today so you guys can already you know get used to like the
pattern of watching both streams at the same time uh you
know get getting used to it anyway um now before we begin we
are going to watch another video you guys might have already
seen this video before but it is the video announcement by
PUBG Blindspot.
Again, huge shout out to them.
Thank you again for reaching out to me.
They're like, we want to sponsor you to organize the very
first NA tournament for this game.
And I was very scared.
Because I haven't organized or hosted a tournament in a long
time because I've been very, very busy.
And at first I was like, are you sure I could just be a
participant?
And you're like, no, we want to have your name, your brand
on this tournament.
And we want you to be the very first the very first host for
our game for this turn so so here we go here we go um so
yeah like I said this is uh fully sponsored by them um and
uh and I cannot wait for next week it's it's gonna oh my
gosh I cannot wait the production side it look is they made
all of these graphics you see this cool animated graphic
behind me a little animated background they've made that
almost all the oh okay not all not almost all the asses i
did they provided me with all the asses i just had to be
here that's the best part as compared to like the other
times i've hosted tournaments uh where i have to like manage
everything i just have to show up yay so they made all these
amazing assets for me to use for the announcement stream so
huge shout out to the production side of PUBG blind spot we
love we love free stuff don't we anyway let's watch another
trailer you guys might have already seen this trailer before
but this was the announcement trailer on my tournament it
does provide some of the details which I will go in depth
later on but here we go 2025 is over so is the way let the
Real games begin.
We don't have much time, so lock in.
Blindspot launches into early access.
A new era begins together with Doki Bird.
Hey, that's me!
This isn't just an update.
Strategy, mind games, and an entire new formula to win.
You're about to witness the evolution of gameplay.
Who will be the first to show us these grand changes?
These are the players that I have my eyes on.
They have their own style, own personality, and are ready to
bring the fun.
Some of them might take big risks, so we'll just play for
Chaos, and others might be the surprise star.
Don't you wanna know what they'll show us?
This match is gonna carry my name.
It's no small game.
That's right, a total of 15,000 USD, and the winner takes
$7,000.
That's a lot of money.
Check it out yourself to see who takes the spotlight.
Where can you catch the action?
Get your notes ready because we got it all right on screen.
Gotta write that down right now!
This match will be broadcast on my channel, Doki Bird!
You don't want to miss it out.
There won't be a second to miss, so tune in and see what
type of crazy plays your favorite creator is going to bring
out.
The plan for victory is ready in motion.
You want to get ahead of the game?
Well, I guess we better tune in and follow closely.
It's your turn to experience the blind spot.
Witness the new era on my stage.
I'll be waiting, but don't be late.
Well, that's right.
A blind spot.
Oh, it is free to play, by the way.
so you can actually get join right now in the early access
it's free to play and we love free stuff just feel free to
click on the link pinned in my two chats on twitch and
youtube or in the description below on the youtube and you
can check out the game yourself guys um okay funny funny
story originally uh the trailer uh was not narrated by me um
but when we were going over it we were like oh it feels a
little you know we want to add more like you know because it
is a dokeyberg tournament and they were like how about you
narrate this instead of like you know the voiceover because
at first i was like whoa the the guy voicing this i feel
like you know he needs more personality in there more oomph
to it and they're like how about you narrate this and then i
accidentally did not see the message for two days and the
deadline was like in two days and i was like oh my god i'm
so sorry i i'm so out of it and i was like i i did it i And
I was like, don't worry, I got you.
Bam, there you go.
Thank you, pre-recorded, Doki.
I really appreciate it.
Another funny story, but the tournament was actually
originally was supposed to be on Valentine's Day, too.
It was originally supposed to be on February 14th, but I was
like, no, that's my dog's birthday.
them letting me adjust the tournament dates because I was
like I'm sorry that's my dog's birthday I gotta celebrate my
dog's birthday on the 14th so like oh that's okay we can
have it the day after it's that okay I was like yeah that's
a lot better that's the day after my dog's birthday I was
like I'm sorry it's true dish so I really appreciate them
being super flexible on the dates itself um so yeah like
they they've been very accommodating very flexible i really
appreciate it uh you're the crazy cat lady but for the time
hey we all we all love dad here okay it's his birthday uh
it's his special day um anyone uh uh let us pull up the
slides you guys are 10th anticipation on who is gonna be in
this tournament uh all right let me all right goodbye big
dokey hello smaller dokey whoa look at that that's me they
made the logo too isn't the logo so pretty dokey bird
creator match pubg blind spot look that's me i like how they
color coded too to my colors as well all right so for those
who are wondering what is pubg blind spot um it is um here's
a little is actually developed by a very small team of fewer
than 20 developers uh who made this game and um it's not
battlegrounds it's not a battle royale in fact it's its own
little thing so you guys might have remembered me playing
this before in a previous sponsor as well so the best part
of this game is that it's free to play so you can actually
try to gain yourself right now in early access and it's
basically like a top-down 5v5 tactical So you know the drill
regarding tactical shooters, so you have a defense and
attack side round and your goal is to either prevent the
team from planting the bomb or be the one to plant the bomb.
So, you know, you remember when during the last time I
played this game in the earlier early axis, like the guy
that we were against, he was like against the wall.
And I was like, I'm going to breach that wall.
And I just like, I just like, I destroyed the wall and he
was just right there.
I was like, shoot him!
So, I hope we get a lot.
I'm definitely going to be breaching a lot of walls next
week.
I'm going to be like, guys, don't worry.
He's definitely going to be on that other side.
I'm going to breach that wall.
Anyway, so yeah, you can destroy walls, wallbang, as you
guys saw in the trailer.
Shoot someone with a grenade launcher, which obviously won't
get...
I'm going to try that one time.
And it's definitely not going to back.
I feel like when you guys see my team, you're going to know
like one of us is going to try that.
And I'm definitely not going to go wrong.
Definitely nothing's going to go badly from that.
And you can use all types of util for an advantage.
And a lot of the utility is mapped to a specific agent.
So like each agent has its own utility, its own specific
guns and everything.
which agent is perfect for your playstyle uh but yeah also
another great thing is that there's shared vision combat so
what that means is that your team shares enemy sightings and
lines a sight in real time so whether your teammate sees you
can see as well so basically your teammate can give you wall
hacks as long as they aren't incompetent and die just just
don't die that's all we ask always have wall hacks as long
as they don't die oh i see also don't worry if you are not
like very into like the whole 5v5 tactical part of the
gameplay there is team death match um if you want to check
out the game yourself like i said there is team death match
for those who just don't want to go just want to go
ungabunga uh but uh but in the tournament we are going to be
playing the um the other game mode which is the search and
destroy so the attack and defense uh so yeah anyway next
slide which i control so i'm telling myself next slide uh
nsd welcome thank you for the five gift and chips thank you
thank you all right so there are some patch notes that uh so
i have to let you guys know for those who have played the
earlier access and have seen the previous stream i've done
for the sponsor stream um they have changed some things um
in this game compared to the last time we looked into it so
Anyway, small dokey will be a smaller dokey now.
Alright, so anyway, so the first thing that they added that
we didn't see before is they added this thing called down
but not out.
So in the previous sponsor, we didn't see this ability
before.
So basically, I know this is going to be super funny when we
do this in the tournament.
lot of things are going to go wrong when this happens in the
tournament uh but basically what this means is that when you
kill someone they don't fall dive so they they're they're
down so you need to double tap them to kill someone uh so
there is a revive system which they added for in the early
axis so they enter a down state and you i can't I can
already imagine one of my teammates who you will find out
later on who it is is gonna be shouting Rizmi he's gonna be
shouting Rizmi come on Rizmi I'm safe it's not me okay it's
not me okay technically it's my entire team my entire team
is is that player uh christmas i'm so safe guys i swear to
god and the okay but another plus side of this new update is
that um they also can they can crawl so so so if you don't
fully kill someone um they can crawl up i can't imagine you
knock someone they just crawl away like where do they go um
but they can crawl away and they do also share vision um
they can also share vision even though if even if they're
crawling um um so the shame crawled i just want to do this
okay if i have a chance in the tournament i definitely i'm
gonna knock someone down and just watch them crawl away i'll
be like all right boy lead me to the rest of your teammates
i know you want to oh you're gonna revive you.
Oh, that's so cute.
Yes, come on.
Lead me to them.
Yeah, I can see some people doing that next week.
Anyway, another thing that they have changed, I believe.
Yeah, they have adjusted him before they wall bang you.
He takes you to one of the walls and you get I don't that's
that at that point.
That's just karma as I played with my food for too long
Other things they have added a mini map Shooting mechanisms
have improved.
They have changed some of the stuff on the maps So like if
you notice some things from the early earlier access like
the ones before
They have changed a few of these things and I had and also
expanded you could decrypt your placement range um i believe
has been yeah they have like a placement range to it now
anyway so these are patch note number one patch note number
two that they wanted me to let you guys know is that they
have added a new character yeah so there's a new new agent
here his name is blaze a new operator uh he uses he has a
molotov gadget and also uses the ump 45 the ump 45 so This
is the new operator that they added for the newest early
access.
And then there's a bunch of adjustments to a bunch of the
other characters like Buddy, Zen, Patch, and Hayes.
So if you guys have played this game before, these
characters have been adjusted for the current early access.
So they are a little bit different.
So Zen, for example, he is only attack only.
You could have played him in defense and attack.
Now he's attack only.
only to attack defense, so you can play her in both attack
defense and change some stuff regarding Hayes' kit in
general, so you can't... What the?
Okay, I didn't even realize this, but in the past, he had a
weapon that had headshot one hit kill.
They thankfully removed that.
Thank God.
That... You know what?
No, that does seem a little broken.
So, that's gone now.
Don't worry.
That is God now.
He does not one shot headshot kill now.
So luckily we're safe Um, so they didn't balance that out
and yeah, they changed buddy's uh gadget as well So now he
has what a camera drone toy penetration gadget.
So that used to be haze's oh my god Hey, oh yeah, I remember
haze had the penetration.
Oh yeah, haze was crazy broken.
I remember now So yeah, he doesn't have any of that anymore
thank god uh all right those are all the new changes for the
current um for the current build of the early access so you
were used if you did play this before if all of these things
changed as well and we got a new new operator blaze all
right next up team captains yes so team captains this
tournament has um it has v-tubers and fleshy's so it's a mix
of both um and the two team captains as it was announced
earlier is me that's me jokie bear uh lily peachy uh muda
and sub sub rose i rosa sorry sub rosa i apologize if i
mispronounce your names i english is my very first language
but unfortunately i am a little bit illiterate i am very
sorry but these are the team captains it is a team of five
for each team so they each pick we each picked our own
teammates for this tournament alright next up prizes the
prize money tournament structure so as I said before this is
a $15,000 tournament and it is fully funded fully sponsored
by PUBG blind spot again thank you again Yay!
Thank you for funding the entire tournament and also helping
me with the assets.
And they also are helping with the casting and the
production.
So the production side of the tournament stream is going to
be a very, what's the word?
Very high quality because they actually got like a cat, like
they actually got real casters instead of like, you know, me
and Mint.
Trying to cast this.
So they got actual professional casters for this.
tournament and also a professional production team uh for
like the camera shots and everything and the swapping
between scenes so i won't be controlling the uh i won't be
solo controlling the entire tournament stream this time like
i have in the previous uh things i've organized so there's
going to be an actual professional production team that's
handling all of that so huge shout out to pubg blind spot
for taking care of all this for me um anyway so first place
is $7,000, second place is $3,000, and third place is
$2,000.
So everybody, everybody wins, except for last place, but
everybody, everyone gets money, except for last, everyone
gets money.
Anyway, other than that, we do also have a special prize.
It's just, just don't get last,
um anyway so there are special everyone wins um not actually
the fine print um and yeah the fine print anyway so so there
are also uh special prizes so each individual uh whoever the
individual who gets MVP, where MVP, the most valued player
in the entire tournament, gets an additional $2,000.
And the kill leader can also get $1,000.
So we do have these two as the special incentives for those
who want to, you know, be like extra sweaty.
So an individual can potentially even get both $2,000 or
$1,000 at the same time.
and MVP.
So technically, last place could technically get Kill
Leader, guys.
They could technically do it.
And I believe, wait, let me message, let me message, just to
be sure.
Because I wasn't fully sure about this one detail about how
MVP is selected.
So let me shoot this message real quick, just to be sure,
because I remember we were talking about this before.
um so um so i just want to fully confirm before i say it
because that'll be a little awkward if i said it and then
the organizers are like um that's uh that's not how we're
doing it so um regarding how mvp is selected anyway so other
than that this is the schedule uh february 6th right now uh
at 3 p.m pst which i just started uh the announcement stream
of all the tournament of the tournament itself.
February 15th and 16th.
Like I said, it starts at the exact same time as this
announcement stream.
But Group Stage will be at 3 p.m.
PST for day one, and Grand Finals will also be at 3 p.m.
PST.
So just letting you guys know, we try to keep it very easy
to remember Every day of this tournament is at 3 p.m.
PST, so we're not like, you know, jump-scaring everyone on
how it's done.
Okay, so I'm just confirming how MVP is selected for this
right now.
But yeah, so group stage is most likely it, okay, not most
likely it is, I am the, I don't know why I said that.
most likely when I am in the tournament but it is a group
stage round robin-esque and then the grand final is where
like the elimination actually starts next slide there we go
I knew it the overview there we go so format uh I oh all
right so MVP this is how MVP is going to be selected all
right so it'll be very uh awkward if there was a different
plan apparently i was not on the same wavelength um they're
like i think what you want is what we will do so they assume
that we are on the same wavelength so okay so this is what i
thought basically mvp will be selected by a vote on my
channel and then i and guys you know you could also vote for
me because i'm also on the tournament too so But anyway, but
no, no, I'm not rigging the votes guys.
We're not I'm not rig.
I'm just giving a Suggestion Wait a minute.
So it will be the vote where MVP guys.
It's just it's just a suggestion.
I'm not rigging anything Um, I was giving an example of how
you can vote.
So it will be a It'll be a vote on the dokey bird Rick got
it Ricky get it no no no no no no no disclaimer I'll give it
a little disclaimer I was just giving an example just a
little you know a little example on how it could work you
know it would be like alright who you guys want for MVP oh
dokey bird alright let's put her name on the pull guys and
it's like dokey bird and all the other options and if
somehow dokey bird wins she gets MVP and $2,000.
But you guys can vote for anyone, even for someone who was
on last place, too.
You know?
You can also vote for someone who was on last place.
It could also be me there, in last place, so.
But anyway, that is how the MVP system will go.
So you all have a choice.
on who mvp is not me but you chat the power is in your hands
guys on who you want to vote for on the dokeybird channel um
who your oh she is also uh who happens to also be dokeybird
so it's it's your choice on how this is gonna go uh sure
but it could be anyone it could be anyone it could be anyone
um anyway so so day one uh day day day one all right guys
how about okay i think it would be more fair i you know i'm
so humble i'm so humble and like i'm for the people you know
so i my own decision i will take myself out of the vote
because I want this tournament to be fair and just and I
know so many people will see me as the most valued player
going in as a person with the most experience going in but
because I am so humble and and I want other people to have a
chance to win MVP I will take myself of the vote to give
everyone a fair opportunity uh hashtag humble
um anyway so day one will be four teams group stage so it is
a round robin um but um the fourth team will get eliminated
before day two.
You're anti-green, disgusting.
Anyway, so the last place team, the fourth team, will get
eliminated on day one.
And then on day two, we will go through the deciding matches
between, it'll just be like elimination from the last
remaining teams.
Another thing to add, uh about this uh I already forgot what
it's gonna say there's no other thing to add that's it that
I mean the format is pretty straightforward four teams fight
it out the team that loses the most gets eliminated on day
one and oh yeah um we made sure to make the tournament not
too long we find it on into one day because we were worried
that it might be too long and people will get tired so uh
because of that we split it into two days and then you know
after tournament they can do whatever they want um so day
two would be a lot shorter compared to day one and all
matches will be played simultaneously so uh the broadcast
will only cover selected matches uh so like there's like a
match if you want broadcast this match but every game will
be played simultaneously so they don't have to wait in
between games you know that's like obviously the worst part
that's why i hate the most when you gotta wait like one to
two hours towards the next game so yeah every game will be
played at once uh to give everyone uh to give every like you
know to move things on like forward in a nice timely manner
um all right next slide whoa captains again all right so
who's gonna be on whose team uh i will start first you will
now understand why i say my team my team is gonna be a
little messy if we manage to work together and not yell at
each other i will call that a win and i created this team by
the way i personally created this team knowing what's gonna
happen all right anyway so my team all right tanya tanydoki
again it will be Me, Kony, Heavenly Father, Super Gomez, and
Sheriff War.
So, um, it was, I was actually the last person to submit my
team because, like, like I said, I had someone drop out last
minute because, uh, they weren't feeling so good.
So they were like, oh, I don't think I could do a
tournament.
So it was like, it's okay.
And then I also was like, um, so each of us, That's why I'm
saying like each of us would be the one to shout res me Like
why didn't you res me each of us it could be any one of us
Um So um It was actually really difficult to create this
team because like everyone was apparently like very busy too
so like I message uh, I message a lot of people and I'm very
thankful Uh to all the people that said yes to be part of my
team and to participate in this tournament.
So huge shout out to Kony, Heavenly Father, Trooper Gomez,
and sure for joining this tournament and being on my team.
Um, this team, yeah.
I forgot.
Was there team kills?
Was there friendly fire?
I don't remember.
I think there, there wasn't, right?
Oh, thank God.
There was no friendly fire, guys.
Thank God.
I just remembered.
Uh, wait, there is.
Oh, no.
Wait, never mind.
There was friendly fire.
My mistake.
Okay, this is gonna...
Okay, I don't remember, but then I remember.
There is friendly fire, so this is gonna be a little messy.
Let's hope...
There's only one way to find out if there's friendly fire or
not.
But anyway, this is my team.
Next up, we have Lily Peachy and the Beasties.
So, yes, all of the Beasties will be participating.
i also want to do another disclaimer we warned her about how
sweaty this this tournament might be oh just just a little
we're not sending we're not sending a child out to die guys
we warned them also also it is a top-down shooter so like so
like if they see the person first if they see the person
first um they can they they can win the fight i believe.
Okay, I believe in them.
All right.
I, we all love the underdog story and I believe in them.
So it is Lily Peachy, Berrybug, PFP, Tori, and Kyrieu.
Um, that will be on Lily Peachy's team.
And I believe in Lily Peachy.
I believe she can lead her team, uh, to victory and not
last.
I believe in her.
Um, but I'm not being last though.
Like if anyone has to be last, I hope it.
I'm sorry, Lily.
If it's me and you and one of us has to be last, I'm sorry.
But, but, but I do not want to be last.
All right.
The next team will be Team Muda.
So in Muda's team, it'll be Cloudy X3, Kamali, NelFPS, and
Dashnerf.
is Muda's team.
But yeah, there they are.
Yay!
I believe they are all very talented in shooters in general.
So, oh my god, there are looks maxing right now.
Yeah, from what I was told, they are gamers.
Gamers.
So, if it's between me and Lily Peachy, To be not last, I am
sorry, Lily, but I will lock in so hard.
I do not want to be like Super, who got knocked out of his
own tournament.
I have to show up on day two, Lily.
I'm sorry.
I have to show up on day two.
I can't give you mercy.
All right.
All right, last team, the very final team, will be Team
Subrosa.
So it will be a GMDD Dynamic, Simone, FPS, and N-Pride.
I do recognize some of the people on this team.
They are all also very good at various shooter games.
And also, I know, yeah, all the teams are pretty stacked.
I know, like, some of them are actually, were pros in other
games.
So, uh, yeah, I know that some of these are gamer gamers who
have been pro players.
I mean, one of them is literally wearing their jersey shirt.
So one of them is literally wearing their, their esports
sport team.
So I assume they are all, I mean, the other guy has two of
them have FPS in their name.
So I, I assume they're very good at FPS, guys.
I, it would be, I mean, if you put FPS as your gamer tag,
you, you must be good at FPS.
Because then that would be a little embarrassing if
you're...
It's just there for fun.
But yeah, anyway, that was Subrosa's team.
And that was all the teams.
All the teams for the tournament.
They were invited by the team captains.
We're invited by PUBG Blindspot.
And we allowed the team captains to select the teammates
that they wanted to participate.
in this tournament so we gave everybody a freedom on who
they want to pick and when they want to join them so thank
you again to the team captains for participating in my
creator match with PUBG blind spot and also to all the
teammates who are joining in as well all right and that's it
yay that is the the tournament info for the dokey bird PUBG
blind spot creator match but we some blind spots but but
don't leave yet don't leave yet guys we're gonna check up
blind spot itself because i actually haven't booted the game
yet since the last time um since the last time i played uh
played it uh which was during the sponsor uh where we were
broadcast uh at a convention so don't leave yet guys we're
gonna check up pubg blind spot and see what else is new who
made the logo um it was like uh the production team the
production team um for pubg blind spot so and everything so
like i said huge shout out to pubg blind spot if you guys
want to support the um support this tournament support um
everyone here support the game itself uh please feel free to
click on the link pinned in my chat on both twitch and
youtube chat or in the description down on youtube because
it does help out a lot all right let's see let's boop and
then big Like I said, I haven't, um, I haven't touched the
game since the last time we played on stream, so, um, I
don't even remember my sense though, to be fair.
I gotta figure out my sense for this again.
I remember we figured out that, um, we liked it when
lacrosse hair, when our movement is based off where we're,
where we're, uh, looking at.
So I remember that.
Alright.
swap scenes but yeah i hope you guys are excited uh for the
tournament um as a reminder wait actually i forgot to do
this all right i love me again that's me well where is it oh
there we go as a reminder everyone the tournament is at
february 15th to 16th and that is on next week on sunday 3 p
.m.
PSD or 6 p.m.
ESD so yeah be there and support your favorite team or
support me because of course I'm you know I'm your favorite
team right you didn't know you don't let Lily when she's
gonna beat no she's gonna beat up Michael not me simple
thank you the super chat thank you thank you but you know it
could you know we could be surprised because it is a top
down tactical shooter and it's usually I feel like it's
peekers advantage because of it because it's like whoever
sees the person's first because it's top down so as long as
you put like you know you point your mouse directly at
someone like you know they'll die like that's on paper
that's how it works so it could you know anyone can win you
know we don't know who's anyone can win guys all right let
me uh oh you don't hear this music right now all right here
we go all right i gotta make sure you two are visible give
me a sec but out all right here you go yes i know there's
two there's three of you guys two timmies all right let's
see you bump bump bump bump all right here we go i accept i
gotta accept the stuff real quick oh jockey bit there's no
way somebody already stole my name yay my name is still
nobody stole my name thank god i was gonna say there's no
way Someone already took my name while I was introducing the
tournament.
That would be pretty awkward.
My Timmy's and Yimmy's will cheer me on.
Alright, let me see.
I'll do a flow screen window.
Where is the sensei?
Oh, there it is.
Aligning upwards.
I don't remember.
I don't know if it...
I think it rolls over.
Yeah, this looks like it rolled over.
okay and there was like there was something that i was just
like i was like on and off about and it was the where was it
it was the one where it's like wherever you're facing is
where you're shooting at show control show blackout pings
i'm not sure if it's here controls master aim camera line
camera rotation oh there you go align choose how to okay
there you go align aiming upwards manual there align always
align curse okay there you go do that
alright here you go but I do the tutorial again so wherever
I'm so this is where I can turn my camera and then let's
walk through slowly I'm walking through very slow oh there
you go oh oh wait that's crouch crouching and walking
through wait they changed the tutorial this is different
thing there you go go to the next location it is so slow
what do you mean all right switch to secondary there you go
go to the next location I love ruining.
What do you mean?
Alright, fire at target.
Yeah, they changed the tutorial a little bit.
It's different.
Oh, aim low.
Okay.
Aim low at target area.
Too close to the wall.
What do you mean?
I'm reloading?
Aim low at target.
oh my god it's so different now or maybe yeah it feel it
definitely feels different i swear to god i made me low what
am i doing wrong what am i i am pressing control this is
control oh my god i re-binded it that's why wait i remember
i re-binded the controls Give me a sec.
I forgot what I binded it to.
It's not them.
It's me.
I re-binded the controls.
I remember now.
I was like, I don't understand.
Because like, control was not crouched at first.
And then I was like, I don't like that.
I'm gonna make it control is crouched.
And I realized, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
That makes more sense now.
What was it?
What did I put it as?
I don't remember.
It's, okay, okay.
Mouse, aim.
Oh, it's C.
Oh my god, it was C.
Why did I put it as C, Doki?
It's not, it carried over.
It actually carried over.
All the past Doki's control was carried over into this game.
Past Doki.
I was in C.
I don't understand.
Alright.
Why did I put it?
Yeah.
I don't.
Why did I put it?
I see.
What the heck was mouse button then?
Alright.
Guys.
I need to rebuy my stuff.
I don't know what past turkey was thinking.
I don't remember what past turkey was thinking.
What was my mouse button?
then okay melee attack was mouse okay that was the mouse
button what about the other mouse but rotate camera what was
I thinking okay what was that thinking clearly I wasn't all
right it's fine it's fine all right that means that means
this one aligning it okay here you go confirm area so then
that means there we go all right because i liked it yeah cc
is crutch but i was like i don't like that i'm gonna change
it wow
what was pastoki thinking i'll never find out all right go
to the next location My special gadget.
What is it?
I gashed the wall.
I did it.
Kel, thank you for being a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fast Doki struck again.
Alright, let's watch in my tactical gadget.
Watch my nade.
Alright, I got that.
Oh my god, you can throw your nade so far.
remember that.
Aim great.
Your grenade up.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I remember that now.
There we go.
Alright, go to the next location.
Watch this.
Grenade out.
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
Just a little friendly fire.
I'm just practicing.
Just practicing friendly fire for my team.
It down all.
I don't know about it.
Wait, can I hit from...
Can I wallbang glass?
No.
Oh, wait.
That's the grenade, right?
Yeah, look at that.
I think...
Yeah, I remember, like, in the end, I liked facing towards
where I'm planning on shooting.
I felt like that was, like, the most convenient overall.
All right.
One more to go.
Where's the last one?
Oh, right in front of me.
There's gonna be...
I gotta let them know.
I'll be like, There is friendly fire, guys!
There is friendly fire!
Guys!
Alright.
I wanna buy agents.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, give me a sec.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm gonna do something pretty magical.
Watch this.
Give me a sec.
I...
Do I do this?
Oh, wait.
I already did it.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna do something really magical.
You're gonna be, like, so impressed.
Watch this.
It's like a...
It's like that code, you know?
You put a code down, and then suddenly you have...
And suddenly something magical is happening.
give me a sec it's gonna oh wait what what is what do you
mean there we go look at this and now oh wait you guys can't
see sorry uh yimmy's covering it up but but look at that i
did a special input i did like up up down down left right
right down left and then oh my god i'm rich now i'm how does
she do it see i know the secret is the special input the
special input where after you put it in you get 12 000 uh
these okay so oh i can buy all of them okay i'm gonna buy a
patch i don't remember what all of them did i remember haze
was pretty broken and then i could buy two more and then i
guess fuck the other guy uh oh i should buy blaze because
he's new also i realized blaze reminds me of axel wait he
reminds me of axel and it was so funny because he like
messaged when i got my when i announced my tournament he
messaged me because he thought it was the uh original pubg
battlegrounds game because he's been craving pubg
battlegrounds and he was like wanting like an actual custom
in na and then he was like oh my god are you full can i
still can i still join and i was like Axel it's a different
game I was like it's a different game it ain't Battle Royale
Axel it's a top-down tactical shooter and he's like oh dot
dot dot I was like do you still do you still want to do it
and he was like no because he wanted to play PUBG
Battleground.
He was just craving for PUBG Battleground.
Alright.
We get Buddy or Zen.
Actually, he has Sticky Launcher.
Drill Camera.
Oh, I'm not.
I don't know how to do Intel.
I'll just buy it.
I'll just buy Zen.
I don't know.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm bad at Recon.
I don't remember which one I liked the most.
You guys remember which one I played?
A lot of.
like spamming i think it was fanatic right because she had a
med kit was it fanatic or who was it go back to baddie i
mean buddy do you guys remember which one i played uh the
last time i played this game it's like i'm trying to
remember because i liked a specific gun it was a specific
gun that i really liked no it was like it was an aim gun and
the shield i remember i played him i played him during
defense he was no it was the guy with the hammer i was
breach man i don't no guys did you forget the explosive
hammer i was the breach man oh wait
actually yeah i said all how could i forget about you
actually we'll do team death match first
i was the breach man Only one guy can reach, and that would
be me.
Alright, let's do...
This is a team death match.
I want to try out the different guns.
We'll do...
We'll try it.
We'll test it out.
Alright, I believe in us team.
We just gotta shoot.
Oh, never mind.
Just gotta shoot each other.
Oh, where is he?
Where is he?
Oh, shit.
shit.
Wait, oh my god, he shot his teammate!
Oh my god, that was so fast.
Oh my god, I gotta remember there is friendly fire.
Oh my god, where are they?
Where are they?
I'm so paranoid.
Guys, where is my shared vision?
Oh, they are cooking us right now.
Oh my!
Oh my god, stupid shared vision!
Why don't you give me the shared vision?
No, there is an absolutely friendly fight.
Holy shit.
I'm a team.
I'm sorry, team.
It's my first game.
Wait, shared vision.
There we go.
See?
It's possible.
Anybody can win.
It's Peekers' advantage.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, see?
There you go.
Shared vision.
Wow.
Oh, my guys.
Guys.
Come on, guys.
Okay, I am a little messed up right now, though.
I really need healers.
Watch this.
Boom!
Oh, shit.
Double kill?
All me, guys.
All me.
All right, I'm going to go back to base, home base, to grab
HP.
There you go.
Double HP?
Oh, I don't have shields.
Look at that.
Double kill.
See?
my brain.
Okay, it's a 30.
All right, there you go.
That's awkward.
Don't work.
Boom.
That'll work again, surely.
I told you that'll work again.
I told you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I know he's right there, too.
What?
Oh, my God, that that shotgun was so far oh shit okay i'm
already i'm doing my part though i did i'm doing my part in
this team where everyone's crouching like a pussy there you
go i got you i got you and then my team shot me
bro everyone's just like like a little baby there you go
surely somebody will walk over there Oh my god.
Okay.
He's so bad.
See, I figured it out.
Guys, I told you I could figure this out.
Oh my god.
He is one.
Come on, guys.
We just need one kill.
I cannot do everything.
Yay.
Yeah
Yeah I did it Yeah I'm pretty sure Yeah I was gonna say I'm
pretty sure Most skills most damage dealt 10 by 10 by 10 by
the way by Look it took me a while to get started It took me
a while to get started But like after I figured it out guys
after i figured it out i locked in i locked in we have
someone with 7 accuracy at least they're not on my team
they're not on my team so it's okay see we did it all right
now let's actually be tactical all right now we go into the
big boy leagues the big boy Big boy leagues now
Alright What step noise can be greatly reduced by walking Is
that why everybody's walking?
Oh my god, it's gonna mess me up Where's the, where's
Breachman?
No!
Breachman!
I don't know what else to play now!
That was the only guy I knew how to play Oh I don't know.
Oh, okay.
All right, I'm a cat girl now.
The plan.
My entire plan relied on playing one person.
And now it's over.
It's...
There you go, here.
Whoa.
that was my entire plan all right how do i play this person
um hand foam grenade and um guys what is my util this was my
entire plan oh my god that shotgun is have a hammer guys all
right what the what is he shoot him shoot him him why didn't
you shoot him i was gonna shoot you i didn't want a friendly
fire
what was what was the plan oh oh my god i was about to throw
this i was about to he's fine don't worry i got you buddy
wait did we double tap returning to combat did we double tap
Oh my god, I don't even get to get res.
What do you mean?
I did a good thing.
I'm like...
I did a good thing and I get punished for it.
I swear...
Okay, that was a good wall bag.
I had no res for you.
I did a...
Guys, guys, the A...
Guys, you have...
Dot, God, you have Bob.
What are you?
I can't believe it.
It's alright.
My team did it.
It was okay.
My team.
My team did it.
Alright.
We did it, guys.
We're so good.
I'm gonna be so useful now.
Alright.
We're attack again.
Okay, I need to figure it out.
We're in more.
don't charge what all right what does he do guys like they
took the one character i knew how to play like what am i
okay i got it i'm gonna throw the motion sensor right here
so we get flanked if we get flanked then i'll know all right
where are we going i follow lu also why the heck was he over
there So you don't get maxed out.
I'm so scared.
I'm so paranoid of friendly fire now, guys.
I'm so paranoid.
I feel like I'm going to actually shoot my team.
All right, here you go.
Flash out.
Did he just flash himself?
You wanted a challenge.
guys you don't understand here you go you have the hammer
jesus all right there's no one there this time oh my god i
mean i can still shoot it like it's not like i can still
shoot this like it's not like you know wait he's dead right
the colors are gone back
up a bit all right don't worry they'll
Don't worry.
Motion sensor!
Watch out!
They'll never see.
Oh my god, they saw.
They'll never know.
I lost my sensor.
Don't worry, they'll never... I got the second sensor.
Oh, there you go.
See?
They never expect a second sensor.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I'm scared.
Wait, I have bomb.
Oh, my bad.
Wait, no, everyone has bomb, right?
What's that thing?
All right, I'm planting.
Cover me, cover me, cover me, cover me, cover me.
Right there, yep, there we go.
Motion sensor, placed.
They were...
Oh, no.
One enemy left.
They won't know.
Yeah!
I didn't have to do anything.
Let's go!
Yay!
Wait, that motion sensor goes hard, though.
Wait, I figured it out.
No, no, no.
I was the backup flag.
I couldn't shoot because he was in front of me.
What if I shot my team, guys?
like guys i could have shot my team i was trying to not
shoot him because there's friendly fire i got scared i got
scared if he yeah see i i practice restraint chat i practice
restraint in not accidentally killing my team and that's all
that matters i have to be able to restrain myself before the
tournament
all right this is a new attack now cameras live all right
you got this new hammer that
damn okay
Oh shit It's crazy for that
Oh shoot that guy Shoot up Okay I was gonna say I don't
really want to shoot that guy Oh
I swear I saw Wait Wait there's a guy right Oh shit Wait.
There you go.
There was another guy right here.
That's right.
One bang!
Oh, I know you're...
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
That's right.
Never expected me on the other side!
Okay, we're...
This is the most tactical I've ever been.
All right, now it's defense.
What was the best for defense?
It was like...
Oh, this one.
I remember I used her because I had Medkit.
I can just heal myself.
I'm so tactical.
Look at that.
These guys are super new, new.
That's me.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
I shall...
What was it?
Alright, deploy a barricade.
And then...
They'll never expect this.
Or this.
That's right.
And then...
Barricade!
Alright.
Even...
Alright, I don't know why we breached that.
Okay, it's fine.
and then what if i barricade this wall too and then and then
i'm gonna put a i'm scared i'm gonna put medkit right here
medkits here in the open
this is bait don't worry the medkit is bait the medkit is
just bait oh my god where the fuck do i stand where i won't
get shot there we go this is where do i position where i
don't get shot i am very scared i'm so safe here surely
right oh my god i forgot about this area too oh my god
there's so many angles why did we destroy that wall
where do i even look where do i even look where do I where
do I look why do we destroy that wall okay it's five
nobody's gonna come over here we're so safe one enemy left
oh nice oh wait it's one enemy left I can just roam it's
roaming time
you just roam where could the last be though oh 30 seconds
remaining where is he oh shit could he be just oh my god
that guy's just destroying everything hello he went outside
10 seconds remaining wait did he like did he okay Oh my god,
he was back over there.
We did it guys.
We won Yes, look at that.
I'm ready for the tournament.
I'm so ready
We're so ready for the tournament guys It's that easy see
all right one more One more but yeah, you guys want to check
out the game right now you can it's literally a free to play
and it's an early access at the moment so you can actually
try the game right now and you can download the game by
clicking the link on my chat pin in my chat uh use the
command or or the description under youtube under my youtube
stream
yeah and you can play right now match found
all right here we go again
uh what do i i like the motion sensor girl only because like
i'm so paranoid
I'm so goddamn paranoid.
I feel like the motion sensor helps with that.
Wait, unless someone...
Is anyone playing Lulu?
Wait, wait, I'll get to be Hammer Boy!
No one's Hammer Boy!
Oh my god.
Free Hammer Boy.
Alright, here we go.
Is it really paranoid if they're actually out to get you
don't say that it's time it's time that it's hammer time
it's like oh my god did you see that crazy tweet from the
creators of digital circus and she was like and people were
like we're like why did you they're like you are actually
being watched that's right your favorite characters Oh my
god, why would you tweet that?
Yeah.
Did you actually tweet?
I was like, you are actually being watched.
I was like, oh my god, that's crazy.
That's actually a crazy thing to say.
What?
I didn't even have a chance.
Oh my god, I looked out at the window one time.
How do we get the crawl?
don't even get the privilege to crawl.
I just wanted to hammer.
I wanted to hammer.
Well, that guy's crazy.
Oh my god, the jiggle peeks though.
It's okay, my team can carry me.
I believe in my team.
She's planning.
Look at them go.
Well, How do I expect the next person?
Wait, that is so smart.
Write this down.
Guys, write this down for my tournament.
Wait, that is so smart.
Why is this face?
The pawn plant is next to the window.
Guys, write this down.
I will choose this map so I can plant right here.
I will plant it right here.
Guys, write this down so I won't be last place.
the coldest not last oh my god my team is smart the enemy
can do yeah but if we do it first it'll be different guys i
don't think hammer boy is good in this map maybe
yeah note to sell platinum year windows i have a feeling
that maybe maybe hammer boy might not be for this particular
area.
Oh, that guy's level 8 already.
I might need more than a habit.
Alright.
See you guys, but I'm figuring it out.
Slowly but surely.
I'm relearning the game for next week.
It will work out eventually.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
Alright, I'm going to believe in my team to show me the way
all right reloading cover me i have motion oh wait is that
same bad spot no oh my god it is
there you go there's no way oh my god they're fracking out
oh that's crazy i literally looked at one second
Oh my god, he's right there.
I'm scared, guys.
He just want to hop.
He just want to hop spin and plant.
We got you.
He's like, come on, you got this.
I got to be
the smartest shit I ever done.
What the fuck he crouched?
He fucking crashed so I couldn't shoot at him!
Ah!
He crouched!
Oh my god!
That's so sweet!
You can do that!
You can just crouch!
Okay, now I know.
Yes, now I know in the tournament.
In the tournament, I should just crouch.
I was like, I got him.
And then he started crouching.
The crouch technique.
It like clicked in my head.
I was like, bro, mad mad's crouching.
I can't even shoot him in the head His entire body was
fucking crouched Just okay now I know I'll just keep
crouching Bro That's why you gotta shoot the toes You gotta
shoot the goddamn toes Just crouch He knew how to Drop shot
like it's 2007 Alright guys Note this down.
Note this down.
We have to...
We have to crouch when we're shooting.
We gotta shoot the toes.
Now we know.
We shoot the toes.
They'll never expect flat B.
A third dive.
I think they're all going...
Wait, what?
Where are they going?
What?
Okay.
That hurts me
Okay, guys, I don't know the util for that so blue hurts me
apparently Who would have thought It's okay my team's
picking it up for me.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing, but my team is doing
it
Where's my plant the bomb?
Oh shit Okay, what is he what is he doing what is did he
see?
Did he did he see what the fuck was this plan?
The same thing.
So let's just get a lot of like detail to throw
No, I think our third guy actually DC'd I yeah he's gone i
was like oh no no he's gone god oh no wait wait this is
loosable now this is loosable what all
right don't worry guys Razor wires down.
What if there's a third razor wire?
Don't worry, there's no way they wall banged this.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
No, after one minute.
No, my monitor is going to turn off after one minute.
It has to do a little maintenance.
Oh, no.
I have to live in one minute.
This is so bad.
After one minute.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Wait, he killed his friend.
One minute dream.
No, I won't be able to see the monitor.
Boom incoming.
One minute remaining.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
That actually hurts me.
Oh,
no.
I'm going to go the other side.
Oh, well, no.
My monitor.
See?
No.
It had to do a bit.
Oh, no.
Okay, we can fix this.
I'll play on my second monitor.
We can figure this out.
Okay.
All right.
I'm looking on my via my OBS my OBS.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I can't swap it to my second monitor.
I actually have to play on my OBS.
Okay.
All right.
We can do this.
Okay.
Okay, there, it's fine.
Guys, I don't know if you guys can tell, but I'm playing via
my OBS right now.
My OBS is creepy.
Oh my god.
This is so bad.
It's doing a maintenance right now.
Oh no.
setting wire throw him a gadget oh no this is so bad for me
oh my god
it truly is a blind spot i'm actually i'm like trying i'm
full screen play on my obs trying to make this work guys i
really am
my monitor had to go into maintenance mode at the last
second i'm sorry
it's so tiny everything is so tiny on the screen it's okay
we can make this work if we lose this because i don't even
have my monitor on i I simply have the perfect excuse chat.
I don't my monitor is off Guys, I have actually the perfect
excuse my monitor is off
Monitor please come back Because I don't think the monitor
is coming back.
I don't think so Setting wire mine set razor wires down i'm
gonna lock my oh wait actually
oh my god i don't feel so good
i'm so scared i hear so many people mine destroyed when the
gadget i feel like i'm heading back
Oh my god, it's okay.
I'm just down.
I am so reasonable.
I'll give you it.
There you go.
I'll give you.
I'll give you a little...
Oh!
Guys, guys, I'm...
Look, I should have thrown sensors, but also, guys, I am
playing...
Oh my god, my main mod and just...
Oh my god, my... What is he doing?
Oh no!
My mod and just turned on!
That's the worst.
My monitor actually just turned on.
No!
Okay, okay, I can't be useful now.
I can't be sort of useful now.
I...
Dang.
Okay, my monitor came back on, guys.
We can salvage this.
all right here you go now i can lose with vision exactly
exactly now all right
this is come come back time i can now i can lose with vision
i've never had that happen before i've never had that happen
before with my fucking monitor that like does a maintenance
mode mid to stream but goddamn wild oh nice that was
convenient wait i got you guys oh wait they just oh my god i
did it guys i helped she was wild oh my god see one enemy
left
What's behind us?
Guys, see?
My monitor was on.
My...
I told you.
I was the deciding factor.
All right.
I contributed.
I got monitoring.
It was all fire at the plant.
They're like, God, we have this stupid dokey bird on our
team.
She's not doing nothing.
And then I was like, yeah, because I was playing with my
monitor off.
Like, I was like, I wanted to make this game fair, you know,
for the other team.
So I had to play with it off.
I don't know.
Oh, but you want, I guess because you guys want to win, I
guess I'll turn my monitor on now.
I almost throwing, but winning makes forgotten.
Look at that.
Jeez.
I can't read the shit out of that last game.
So good.
I just have to turn them on.
All right.
Thank you again.
Like I said, thank you again to...
But Twitch.
Timmy's.
Don't go yet.
Don't go yet, Timmy's.
Because I'll be staying a little bit longer on Twitch.
But.
Yimmys.
Actually.
I don't know if I can do that.
Can I do that?
Wait, I can.
All right.
Uh, to the yimmies.
Thank you all for coming Uh, to the stream.
Yes, because I'm gonna I'm gonna do another game.
I'm gonna play something else.
So like, you know, be weird on the on the YouTube vibe.
Uh, I'm gonna be swapping to another game.
Um, but I want to say thank you again, uh, to pub G
Blindspot for sponsoring today's stream and the tournament
and the announcement.
Please check out the tournament next week on February 15th,
2 and 16th.
Let me pull it up real quick.
Wow!
Oh, hey, that's me.
That's me right there.
All right.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Also, I hope the volume was okay.
I did not sound check at all.
I hope the volume wasn't too loud.
guys i was not but a little reminder for everybody but the
tournament will be on february 15th to 16th at 3 p.m pst so
make sure to be there to support your team and me for this
tournament i'll see you guys next week everyone um but yeah
i will still be streaming on twitch but thank you again uh
if you guys want to support me the stream the game the
tournament uh the teams that are the link pinned in both
chats both youtube and twitch chat or in the description
below um it really does help out uh the channel the streams
and the sponsor a lot and by the way uh you can play pubg
blind spot right now for free it is free to play so you can
check out the game yourself all right guys to the youtuber
youtube chat as always everybody say hydrated pause check
get up and move around get that blood flowing stand for me
head to bed because you deserve it uh to twitch Goodbye
right now to YouTube.
Goodbye YouTube.
I actually never tested this out.
So we'll see if I can stop YouTube and keep on going on
Twitch.
So we can't say goodbye to both of you guys.
So we're going to try this out for the first time.
Goodbye YouTube.
Goodbye.
Am I still on on Twitch?
Am I still on on Twitch, guys?
It worked, guys.
Yeah.
It worked.
Yeah!
All right, now we're here.
All right, let's go back here.
All right.
All right, goodbye, YouTube.
Goodbye.
Oh, wait.
All right, let's put Twitch chat here.
All right, now it's just Timmy's.
where's my youtube outro because the out because technically
if you think about it we haven't had the stream hasn't
technically ended yet so there is no outro we just say
goodbye we're gonna play i don't know i'm gonna boot up my
other stuff first real quick uh before i mean we have an
hour and 30 minutes before uh the member stream so uh let me
make the waiting room tweet real quick.
Oh, I forgot to end stream on YouTube side.
All right, there we go.
Now it's worked.
I forgot to click end stream on the YouTube side.
Yeah, I can't just stop the stream.
Yeah, I was about to say, Killingmore, thank you for the
Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
All right.
We ended the stream for real, though.
I forgot, like, I can't just click stop streaming.
I have to also, like, end the stream on, like, physically
press end stream.
All right.
Let me... All right.
Let me see.
What should we do today?
What should we do?
I mean, I want to make my waiting room tweet for members
real quick, guys, before we do anything.
waiting room tweet for men in black oh yeah we're not
sponsored no more so we can i mean we could play marvel
rivals we could technically i don't know i'm so bad i don't
understand deadlock i don't understand i also i uninstalled
deadlock so we gotta i i also uninstalled deadlock so um Oh,
we could try out Overwatch.
But, oh, the new characters aren't out until next week,
though, chat.
The new characters aren't out yet.
Yeah.
We can't.
I want to wait until...
I want to wait until Overwatch, the new character comes out
before we do it.
Let me change the title real quick.
Figuring it.
Figuring out.
Figuring it out.
And it will do chatting just in case.
We'll do chatting.
Half-Stored got released.
Maybe test that.
Yeah, but I want to play Half-Stored.
Half-Stored on YouTube.
All right, but before I do, let me, like I said, let me make
my waiting room tweet.
And then we'll just figure this out.
We have an hour and 30 minutes anyway.
Let's see.
Where is I haven't eaten at all today.
I was, like, so stressed out about this.
whole tournament thing um like i had a morning cry earlier
today uh because like there was like a lot of last minute
changes and like i was like freaking out because i was like
we're oh my god what do i talk we we're missing this info i
was having like a a i was like i was so stressed out And I
was like, oh, no, we have to start streaming later.
Ah!
But I'm glad everything worked out in the end.
You know, I'm glad.
I'm glad we, I'm glad you guys don't notice that I was
fucking panicking.
Like, literally, like, an hour before the stream was going
to start.
I was having a breakdown.
I was just like, ah, what do I say?
Ah!
But I'm feeling a lot better now.
I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
everything uh flowed naturally in the end i mean i'm i feel
like i'm very good at like improv or like uh just in the
moment in the moment i'm really good with like uh how do i
say it like just being able to uh go with the flow in the
moment but if i'm like but before it happens because i like
go into streamer mode real quick, I click into the streamer
mode, um, persona.
I don't say persona, but like perspective, I guess.
And, and then like, I, my mind just like does everything
like, um, does everything like instantly.
And, but if I'm not streaming, if I'm not streaming, I'm
just panicking.
I'm freaking out and panicking because I don't know what to
when i'm not streaming yeah the mindset i just switch into
the mindset and then like i know how to like salvage
situations or like uh just fix stuff like on the fly type
deal but when i'm not streaming is i'm just panic i'm just
like in full-on panic mode because i'm like what do i do
like i'm not streaming right now i don't know what to do all
right let me do a membership here's the waiting room been
craving Been wanting to do, to catch, to rewatch Men in
Black for a very long time.
So let's start today.
Oh my god, then tomorrow is my anniversary.
Oh my god, I'm so nervous about tomorrow.
I hope everything goes okay.
I also had a nervous breakdown.
When are you not having, no, you, it's because like
everything is like, everything is like, piling up this month
like it's literally hell month for me it's it actually is
hell month like everything is just non-stop like uh non-stop
uh work or events or sponsor so uh so like it's just a lot
and i'm next week is also a lot but i'm excited for i i'm
taking a holiday i am taking like a week and a half holiday
in march because like um um um i'll be going to uh i mean
it's gonna be obvious when it i won't say i shall i'll say
it i'll say it on march but like i won't say it now just
because obviously i don't want to we want to get doxxed but
um i'll say it in march like uh i'm gonna be traveling in
march as well um and it's funny because at first i was gonna
take sponsors while on vacation on my laptop and then my
manager was like don't like was like are you sure and i was
like it's all right i have like i can use like one to two
one or two of those days it says free day right there so
like i can use those one of those days to take a sponsor i
can do that and then he was like i canceled the sponsor it's
like why there's so much money in and he was like you gotta
rest man you need to actually go on a vacation but i was
just like oh fine yeah he like rejected the sponsor for me
because i was just like but why though it was so much money
i could totally do that on vacation it's like it's just an
hour like I you know you need this vacation he's right he's
right I do I do I today was not good for me today this from
this morning to like um like an hour before the sponsor I
was having like I had two breakdowns because I was so
stressed out and like I was so stressed out with like all
the stuff going on um in general because February is you'll
you guys will you guys will figure out next week next week
you guys will figure out why i was like i was like i was
just like all over the place because there's a lot of stuff
going on behind the scene and also tomorrow too tomorrow
you'll also figure out why um all right let me tweet my oh
where's my also huge shout out to my manager he stayed uh
he's european and stayed up the whole night uh to make sure
um i don't what's self-sabotage and to make sure I don't I
don't I don't explode I don't I don't uh self-destruct he's
like I'll stay he's like it's like very it is very very late
for him so shout out to my manager for that he's like I will
stay up until the end of your stream to make sure everything
goes okay and i was like thank you all right
all right here we go
uh all right almost done making the waiting room guys but
yeah i hope you guys enjoy the anniversary tomorrow a lot of
work was put into it and um i don't know i'm just nervous
i'm just I'm not like, I'm like, I don't know.
It's always, event streams are always like a lot for me.
And like, I only had a month.
I will give you guys like a heads up.
Because obviously, you know, I had like the new year stuff
to do too.
So you know how I had the new year stuff as well.
So all my attention was spent on the new year's prep.
And then so for the anniversary, I only had a month to
actually figure out what exactly I wanted to do.
then I went straight to like anniversary prepping um and so
I was like super like I I didn't have I didn't know what to
do at first so I'm glad that I figured it out at the end
after the new year's so I just hope you guys enjoy it I
really do um all right I think that's my waiting room is
complete all right yay anyway you're a member of your
YouTube member we are going to be watching men in black I'm
super excited because I personally love the men in black
series and I've been looking forward to watching um an
actual good movie for a while now um and I'm glad men in
black is uh the movie of the choice also fun fact I don't
this is uh this is uh unrelated uh out of topic but did you
guys know Timu now offers food now you can order steak off
of Timu I don't know if it's advisable, but you can now
order Timu steak, by the way.
Also, another little fun thing that I wrote down, but did
you guys know that, yeah, what animal is that?
Did you guys see that Morse Critical uploaded a video today
where apparently like the new trend right now with AI is
that they take big content creator videos and then redub it
in AI in Chinese with their voice.
So there is a, so he was showing a channel that was just
redubbing
just like him but if he speaks Chinese like it was no I
think I think that was crazy because it literally sounds
just like him but what if he speaks Mandarin like and like
it's like the speaking style too like the way he talks this
unique way of speaking and also like just his voice in
general and it's so funny It was like the, the, the Toby
Fox, like, um, Toby Fox, uh, you know how he's like, what
was it called?
Like Toho Project.
You know how Toby Fox is like, when he speaks English, he
was doing, like, he was doing an interview in Japanese.
And he was like Toho Project, and, and in, and in Japanese.
And there was that moment with the AI dub, and he was like,
Markiplier, I don't know you want to do what's so funny.
I was just like, it's like, I don't know what you want to
do.
Markiplier.
It's like, what the fuck?
And then the channel had other YouTubers too.
And I was like, oh my, it's just so funny.
I actually like, I know like, you know, it's AI.
But like, I sort of want to know what it sounds like if, If
it was like Koso or XQC dubbed in Chinese, I really want to
know.
I want to know what does Chinese XQC sound like?
I'm sorry.
I just, I'm so curious.
Yeah, Chinese XQC, imagine.
Man, this was the video.
I normally, I haven't watched like Charlie's videos in a
long time, but it popped up in my recommended.
recommended and like i was like china has cloned me and so i
was like what does that mean
i had to watch it i was so curious i think that's that's
crazy i guess
oh my god but yeah that's just a little fun fact that's uh
all right what do we play guys we have technically we have
we have 45 minutes because i do want a little rest period in
between what do you guys want me to check up we do some
steam dumpster diving too and not rivals oh yeah there's
that zoo game i saw everybody playing it wait there's super
bomber man collection oh my god but is it like wait konami
shadow dropped the bomber man I'm adding that to my wait
list.
Sorry, my wish list.
Oh, my God.
All right, we're not playing that now.
I'm just checking out the, what the, what is on here.
What is that zoo game?
I know every, I know like, I wasn't thinking of playing as a
main game.
I don't know.
Wait, when does I have to do it?
Okay, Resident Evil.
I don't do it.
stream for that like I know I said I wasn't gonna play
Resident Evil Requiem but then someone offered me money and
then I was like okay I originally I wasn't going to and then
they're like what if you do it for X amount of money and I
was like all right money is nice let's see uh The power of
money.
It truly is.
Truly is the power of money.
Wait, what is this?
$20 is $20.
Oh, you guys want me to do My Voice Zoo?
I mean, I could try it out.
I was about, I felt like this was like, I mean, it could be
a one-off, but it felt like such a short one-off because
it's just like an idle game.
For those who don't know, My Voice Zoo, it's an idle game
where you voice act several.
zoo animals uh with your own voice and like it for me it
didn't feel like a mainstream game like a main channel game
because it's like it's like it seems like something you it's
like it seems like a quick throwaway game i don't know how
much content i can get out of that all right let's try it
out my voice zoo yeah quick one and done it's very short and
shitty all right let's open our own zoo
Uh...
What's it called?
My...
Voice...
Zoo.
Wow!
Is this the zoo I'll get to take care of starting today?
I'll have to make the animal sounds myself?
That's a little weird.
Hmm, but it does sound kind of fun.
Literally, I bought this game in like one minute and
download...
I bought and downloaded this game in one minute.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, I got a duck!
Alright.
What do I name this duck?
I mean, it's technically a dragon.
Dragon.
Alright, how's that?
Where's my duck?
Alright.
Does that how the duck sound like?
I don't fucking remember what ducks sound like.
That's what ducks sound like.
Oh, I got a sheep.
Alright.
Sheep.
Goon.
How does sheep sound like?
Ah.
Alright, one.
Oh, my God.
That's so good.
Wait, that's accurate.
It's perfect.
How do you sound like together?
they're having a very meaningful they're having a
conversation guys they're just they're discussing politics
right now oh man we gotta get out of there okay what you
mean don't know what Don't sound like you're you're Canadian
300 bitties.
Thank you for the 300 bitties.
Thank you.
We gotta get out of there All right, wait is that is that is
it loud enough?
Is it loud enough guys?
All right How was this is that oh that's a goat and they
sound the same?
Okay, wait Goat goon Okay, I know what do it sound like.
I watch Zootopia.
Louder?
Alright.
I don't know if this is loud enough.
Oh, wait.
This sounds similar, though.
No, it sounds like the duck.
No, we gotta fix you.
They sound pretty similar.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know.
I'm thinking like screaming goat.
We gotta fix him.
He sounds way too similar to the duck.
Okay All right
All right, there you go that sounds like a That sounds like
that's that sounds like a screaming goat right all right
What the goat sound like that's the way I'm gonna look it
up.
I actually don't know what goats sound like.
Okay Goats.
That sounds like a crow.
I just realized.
Goat sounds.
You know what?
Okay.
I figured.
Oh shit!
I'm so off.
There we go.
Yeah
All right, there we go.
That's fine.
Oh, that's a dog.
Yeah, oh, that's a fox Wait, what does the fox say?
Fox goon What does the fox say?
Ring ding ding ding ding ding ding ding.
All right Okay, there
all right here we go what's the what does the fox say that's
that's literally what foxes say all right what's next is
that penguin all right penguins penguin penguin penguin pen
good i'm cold beep
I'm cold I
should say new
It's quiet I'm cold
Alright wait let's adopt Oh I was gonna say we got adopt
expensive ones But we're broke right now Oh man that's a
walrus walrus oh my god we're going to be pokemon's walgun
um where are the ladies walrus
that's what walrus is all this is what they are all they
want to do is fight for the Ladies!
Where are the ladies?
Walrus.
No.
These.
Walrus.
Is that James?
I like these too.
These are my favorite.
The first and second were always like the classics.
All right, who's next?
Oh, is that a bear?
I'm a bear.
Apex Predator.
All right.
but polar good how how would he what how would he say i'm a
bear rar oh man i'm a bear rar all right here we go polar
good i'm
a bear
I like how like everyone here is like everyone here are like
the actual animal sounds and then and then the arctic the
arctic are all skin walkers these are all the skin walkers
go to all right is that caribou oh I'm quirk all right guys
keep keep talking everybody I need you to keep talking where
are the ladies lord ladies this is how it ended three
dragons in a bear suit these are the actual animals except
for this guy this guy this guy might be a spy all right can
i afford it now kids stop believe in boom suddenly I don't
know how caribou sound like.
Caragoon.
Santa's not real.
That's right.
That's why you got fired.
Guys, that's a reindeer.
You go up the reindeer.
He's like, oh my gosh.
Why are you not pulling Santa's late at night?
And he's like, It's not real.
It comes up to you.
Santa's not real.
That's right.
He's not real.
He's going to ruin your children's Christmas.
Santa's not real tonight.
I'm there.
Was I so loud enough?
Is it loud enough chat?
Alright, who's next?
Oh my god, there's so many animals.
Louder, let it look at.
Alright, hero.
Alright, I upped it a little bit.
Where are the ladies?
What is this?
Never tell it a secret.
You'll regret it.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Parrot.
Good.
What?
Okay, wait.
I got it.
What?
Polly thinks you're a pussy.
Oh, my God.
Alright, let's see what he says.
Where is he?
Where's the parrot?
Where the fuck is he?
I don't know where parents live.
I have a rainforest?
Where the fuck does the parrot live?
Okay, that's the game.
I have a rainforest?
Where are you?
Up and left.
Oh, top left.
Okay, I was blind.
I wasn't paying attention where he was located.
all right if
i had a parrot i would teach if i have a parrot i'll teach
him that i was like who's a pussy polly you are the rage
baiting fairy i would make her i would i would i would train
a rage baiting parrot i would 100 that looks like striking
run oh that's a flamingo yeah i knew it sashay away all
right tyra
what's the phrase sashay away american model quote
is that it is that all she says shantae you wait no that
what's the tyra quote or Or is that RuPaul?
Oh my god.
Tyra Banks quotes.
Is that RuPaul?
Oh my god.
Oh I got it.
Wait, I got it.
I know.
How does this go?
Alright.
I was rooting for you.
We were all rooting for you.
Okay.
I was rooting for you!
We were all rooting for you!
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Nice.
It's a throwback.
Did you guys see that Netflix?
There's a Netflix documentary that's coming out based off of
American Model.
America's Next Top Model.
By the way, my mom was obsessed with that.
So I watched a lot of Americans Next Top Model with her.
And like, it was pretty...
Apparently, like, that show was real.
Bro, did you guys know that they did race swaps?
Like, for one of the challenges?
Did you guys even realize they did an episode of that?
Yeah, yeah, they did it.
Like, we gotta go to the next level.
Today, you're gonna be Chinese.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
What?
That's so wild.
I didn't even remember that episode.
I saw a trailer I saw a trailer for like like the
documentary of like behind the scenes of behind the scenes
of America's next top modern the fucking crazy shit they
used to do and like the crazy behind the scenes stuff all
right owl time Ooh, okay, got us.
Algoon.
Ooh.
Ooh, is a bitch.
No,
these birds.
These birds know what's up.
All right, here we go.
What is this?
Is that an eagle?
Oh, shit.
Okay, this is hard.
Wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Okay, I'm not going to move, but don't worry.
Don't worry.
This is a really good idea.
all right is this give me a sec i gotta figure it out it was
this
all right i don't know if this will pick up all right i'm
ready wait ego going all right here we go let's see if this
will pick
Okay, wait, I did time it better.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, let me time it better.
Let me time it better.
All right, here you go.
Wait, oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck.
It's perfect.
All right.
You get, like, the gun.
The fucking America.
The gunshots at the end.
The water.
One shot.
That's all that matters.
All right.
Nice.
Ah, they shot the eagle.
Welcome to America.
God bless the Super Bowl.
All right, what's next?
That's a lion, right?
Okay, wait, I have a good one.
Lion Goon.
Wait, okay, it's...
Oh my god, how did it go?
I've always wanted a brother.
All right.
I was rooting for you.
We were all rooting for you.
All right.
I've always wanted a brother.
Where you can harmonize with these Where you can do you can
harmonize with all your animals I think I think my favorite
is These two the classics, you know, we do you know first
try is perfection You could never outdo your first try and
in this guy We're the ladies or walrus We're the ladies or
And then...
Alright, what else?
Who else do we have left?
See, this is so... I feel like we're almost done unlocking
everything.
Oh, Rhino.
Fuck.
I don't know why Rhino sound like.
Rhine Goon.
What the fuck do Rhino sound like?
I don't know.
Rhino, that's hard.
Okay.
Rhino, Rhino sounds.
What do rhinos even sound like in general?
I never heard her.
What the fuck?
Um...
Oh, wait, I know.
I know, I know now.
Oh, me.
Oh.
There you go.
It sounds like Mars.
That's what they sound like.
I literally looked up Rhino's sound effects.
I am your character arc.
Don't believe me.
Look up Rhino sounds right now.
That's literally what they sound like.
Oh, wait.
That's an elephant.
Wait.
Wait, no, I can't do elephant.
That's not right, is that a...
There you go.
Alright, that's a natural real sound.
Look at that!
I made a real animal sound!
See guys?
I care.
And then use like a little trumpet.
Oh me!
I'm ready for you!
Holy fuck, I'm so stupid.
Oh, we gotta wait.
We gotta wait, but we can hang out with the bird.
Say, can you see?
America!
Oh my god, it's gonna take forever, guys.
Yep, loud.
Yep, more.
I'm a bear.
That's just not real.
Yeah.
All right, God, I can't afford it.
I can afford a hippo now.
Oh, what to do?
Oh, wait, I got an idea.
Uh.
Wait, I have an idea.
I know what to do.
Wait, wait,
wait, wait, I got it.
I like them big.
I like them chunky.
There you go.
Moto, Gune.
Moto, Moto likes you.
We can't buy another one.
Oh, I can't.
I was gonna say I want another one to be like, Mutto Mutto
likes you.
There we go.
A funky course.
What else would the hippo be?
Come on.
I like them big.
I like them chunky.
I like them chunk.
Just record.
Again, I only have three seconds.
That's all I can fit in.
If I could, if I could buy multiple hippos, I will record
the entire Motomoto song around this pond.
I'll record the entire clip just here.
All right, can we afford?
Oh, we can't afford it.
What is this?
Oh, that's just a regular bear.
Bear goon.
I don't know.
What would a- I mean, I already have a polar bear.
What other references can I do?
He's the bear.
Oh, wait.
Oh, what do I do for- Grr, I'm a bear.
Oh, yeah, wait, wait.
Hoor, hoor, hoor, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho,
ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
That's all, Freddy.
Oh, it's-
he's so jolly oh my god what a jolly guy wait we should oh
we can't rename him i was gonna say all right that has to be
a tiger and then that's a gorilla
for haram man
we are the bare necessities of mine
Oh wait, no!
Oh no, that has to be a tiger, right?
He has stripes.
Oh, I have to rename while recording.
No, that's five.
Oh, they have a cat, too!
But that has to be a cat.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yogi Bear, oh, my God.
Does Yogi Bear even, like, around anymore?
like does anyone even like remember yogi bear i feel like
it's like what was it it's like that chick-munk and the
flying squirrel and the moose guy too oh there you go
there's the tiger
tiger goon hi boo boo yeah rocky and bullwinkle i feel like
a lot of like hannah barbara shows are like sort of like
they're like super retro now and there's no like actual
where you boost up No one wants to really do a reboot of
them because I feel like Those types of cartoons are like
Not what kids like to watch these days
Ah yes, the king of the jungle
Yeah, but Scooby-Doo works But like I feel like Yogi Bear
and also Rocky and Bo Winkle Is like shows that don't really
work in today's generations People don't watch like Tom and
Jerry is very popular in Asia, but in NA it's like not like
people don't really watch Tom and Jerry shows anymore
Tom and Jerry shows in Asia are so cute though Is that
another that's a gorilla?
I have something for it.
I have something for the gorilla I have something for the
gorilla.
I just gotta wait we're almost there
I don't think Looney Tunes I think their best Looney Tunes
adaptation was the one where they had what's her name?
Kristen Wig as Lola Bunny I know people were really upset
that Lola Bunny wasn't hot anymore but the show was so funny
like you know like Kristen Wig did was like Lola was Lola
and she was like this crazy soccer girlfriend, but the show
was really fucking funny and then it got cancelled.
I don't like the newer Looney Tunes shows.
The newer one was not as good.
I know they canceled the Tiny Tunes too, like the reboot.
All right.
Okay.
I'm Harambee!
Okay, wait, actually I got a better one.
Harambee lives!
I lose.
Wait, I got an even better one.
Thanks, though, for Harambe.
Harambe.
There you go.
Harambe never dies.
Fuck, there's so many.
I...
Okay, wait.
Wait, there's so many Harambe never dies.
Guys, I think there's...
I only have one Harambe, guys.
Harambe never...
Guys, I have one.
Only one to Harambe is so hard to pick.
All right.
Harambe never does.
Wait, don't you?
All right.
Harambe never falls.
Never falls.
Wait, wait.
We are Harambe.
We are harambe!
Wait, what was it?
What was the meme called?
Killed wife.
Wife gone.
Think about...
Killed wife.
Wife gone.
Wait,
wait, wait.
Killed wife.
Wife gone.
Regret.
I know I'm tired of that's the one.
Is that the one?
Think about wife.
Right.
Regret.
She was wife.
Wife gone.
Okay.
Wife.
Wife gone.
Regret.
Wait.
Wife gone.
God, regret.
Wife, God.
There you go.
Regret.
Alright, I found the perfect one.
Oh shit.
Goon.
I'm Panda.
Okay.
We got We got panda Speak Look, it's panda I don't remember
how to say panda Chinese I don't even remember the Cantonese
name I just don't panda All right Oh, is that slob?
Yeah, I'm on a very Chinese moment in my life.
Because I am Chinese.
I actually forgot, okay, wait.
Panda in Chinese.
I can't believe it.
Oh, shong, wait, shong mao?
I just keep, I just call it panda.
I always call pandas just pandas.
I never called it the Chinese name All right, slough Slough
goon, I got blown my nose for this
All right
It's a slough, he's sleeping, he's Iepi He's Iepi Look, he's
sleeping.
That's what pandas do.
Regret.
Poor wife.
No wife.
Kill your wife.
Wife gone.
Regret.
Oh, wait.
That's a fry.
Be.
Think about wife.
I'll put them closer.
Oh yeah, I heard the nendroids are here now I'm glad
everyone's been getting I know like EU got theirs first But
I'm glad like people in NA and the rest of the world Has got
their nendroids Makes me happy That it's finally here
Alright, let's play a visit to Bird Island
I fucking love Ego dude Thank you Okay,
I can't afford the frog now.
That's the frog, right?
Alright, I got an idea for the frog.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Let's see.
I'm pretty sure...
Oh, yeah, I knew it.
Alright.
to the end of the path.
I was like, I think she's streaming right now, right?
I'm pretty...
I don't know what the context is, but I got the recording.
Yeah, I literally just pulled up her stream.
I pulled her stream, put it on my phone, and just put it on
the mic.
oh there's a bunny yeah live recording of the moment she was
streaming all right we have rabbit wait that is spin the
cell like it never gets oh that's a dog dog cat where are we
missing dog cat bunny turtle Runs and runs as if that's the
only...
I don't know what that is.
Cow...
Snail.
I like this guy too.
I like Taga-Goon.
Meow.
Ouch.
The fiercest animal in the...
in the jungle.
Oh yeah, it does look like a horse.
I wish this charge is up faster.
I would actually pay just to unlock it.
everything i just want to finish this all right dog tab all
right dog oh that's i know dog should be the easiest but
like okay whoo he can't bark on command guys dad can't bark
on command unfortunately or you're like okay wait I got it I
got it
that's perfect I actually love that
little wolf at the end and he's like you know like when dogs
get like they're like super annoyed in the beginning and
then they're like I'm okay now like I'm okay all right what
else do we have left all right 10 000 oh my god dog goon
make me buy some money right now i need some money dog goon
farm me that money keep farming quick i need to finish my
zoo before my member stream that you're very good at barking
i have very very dog-like to be fair i have i have owned
dogs since i was since um i have lived with dogs since i was
born so like i've been surrounded like i've listened to a
lot of dog barks uh but thank you for the bitties gordon
thank you thank you this is my favorite place to hang out
because of honestly because of the ego
america say can you see All right.
Oh, okay.
That cat is cute.
It's a black cat or gray cat.
Cat wound.
This is hard.
Mondays.
Okay.
I know you get the meow in there.
I see that.
Why is she in the Savannah?
Learn to admit.
Why are you in the Savannah?
Come with us to come with the dog.
I've never had a cat with a dog before.
I'm actually curious if dad would like to hang out with a
cat.
Doggo, why did you interrupt her son?
This is why she never finished her son.
They have to grow up to get it all.
Unlucky.
Yeah, I was like, I wonder if dad will be okay with cats.
the... the tiger.
He
finished it!
He finished the song!
That's cute!
Look, he finished the song for us!
Meow!
I
like some chunk brother!
We were all for me!
I was rooting for you!
We were all brooding!
All right, now we can finally buy the rabbit.
Oh, man.
I don't know.
I don't know the rabbit, Bunny.
Why is she with the...
Why is she with the caribou?
Oh, wait.
What's up, Doc?
All right, nice.
That's how she works.
That actually works.
You go.
What's up, Doc?
Where are the ladies?
I'm Boris.
What's up, Doc?
Where are the ladies?
I'm Boris.
Oh, wait, you're right.
Since...
Oh, I can't change the name.
Technically, technically, she's on...
She wanted to be here, guys.
Technically, she wanted to be near the...
It was automatic!
I didn't tell her to be there.
She chose to be in the snow.
Oh, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
This is my lovely suit.
You guys like it?
All right.
At the end, I'm going to put them all together.
Oh, it takes so long to charge up.
Curse book code symphony.
Whenever I have to wait, I stay here.
have to wait for my currency I
did it we made it all right turtle time oh what would be a
turtle turtle goon I don't know for a turtle
hmm oh I could be like Squirtle, right?
Squirtle.
Squirtle, squirtle.
Dirtle.
Dirtle, dirtle.
Wait.
Teenage mutant ninja turtles.
Teenage...
Cow.
Okay.
Dirtle.
It's like squirtle.
But it's turtle.
Dirtle.
All right.
What does this sound like?
Dirtle.
Come on.
It sounds like the squint, you know, the squirrel use water
gun.
Turtle Goon use water gun.
Who is that Pokemon?
My little, my turtle goon.
Can you bring that caribou?
Alright, let's bring the caribou.
Alright, let's see how he sounds like with the rest of the
game.
Alright.
No, I don't think he...
Do you really think he fits with them?
Yeah, you see?
All right, we were almost close to horse.
Oh, horse time.
Wait, oh, I got good one.
him horse goon wait okay
i got a good one how does it go i need to rewatch this
james baxter james baxter james baxter james baxter I love
the James Baxter.
It's the fucking adventure.
It's James Baxter, the horse.
He's so cool.
He's so fucking cool, guys.
Yay.
For those who don't understand that reference, James Baxter
is the most talented animator in the world.
He's like a crazy good animator, and he animates a lot of
stuff by himself.
himself and Adventure Dime did like a little episode
dedicated to him where he animated himself as a horse uh on
a ball and then all he says is James Baxter James Baxter and
that's all he said he literally shows up just the flexes
like animation yeah just a horse that stands in a ball and
and it was pretty cool it was pretty awesome all right three
more there we go james baxter james baxter oh my god we're
almost done three more
oh there's cow next he was way
then let's kill the horse oh yeah oh yeah you wanted to kill
the horse.
All right, cow town.
Cow goon.
Why does the male cow have udders?
Have you guys ever watched Have you ever watched Barney?
Guys, why do all the male cows in Barnyard have other?
There are no male cows.
If you ever watched the movie Barnyard.
If you ever watched Barnyard, for some reason, the main
character who was supposed to be a male cow.
He has others.
The male cow have others.
and then you're like, all right, gosh, milk me.
And then I'm like, what?
Why does the male cow have udders?
All right, chick mugs.
And then the last is a snail.
Yeah, it's dad too.
Oh my God.
My beautiful zoo.
I'm going to start moving them here.
I'm going to start moving them into my campsite.
Why?
We're moving them all close while we wait.
We'll put them all here.
Alright, here you go.
This is a beautiful orchestra.
It's time to get over simulated, guys.
Wait, he should...
Oh no, they're combined!
Is there anything over here?
No.
I should be able to afford...
Alright, chick mugs.
Chip.
Goon.
Oh, what about chip?
Oh, Hamtara?
Oh, that is good.
I don't remember the Hamtara song right now.
Oh, wait!
I have an idea.
Chris.
Christmas Christmas time Christmas Christmas Oh wait
Christmas Christmas time Christmas Christmas
I forgot to press the button
It's Alvin
Alright we're almost done We have two more Oh
say what do the voices say oh my god last one
the voices the voices
what do the voices say don't keep okay i should oh my god
it's 25 we're almost there we're almost there i'm going
insane Alright, snail time.
Oh my god, what the fuck do I do with a snail?
Snail goon.
What do I do with a snail?
Yeah, but we have meower right now.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, get over here, snail goon.
Join the army.
There's a stale!
That's what stale sounds like.
Alright, nice!
We did it!
We completed the game, guys!
Can you guys hear me?
Guys, can you hear me?
Which one is the streamer?
Who is who?
And was that one?
We finished...
Oh, wait, we got...
We unlocked the Windy Hill.
Do we get more animals when we go up?
Oh, no, we don't.
Oh, my God.
We beat the game, guys.
See?
I told you.
I was like, there's no way I can make this a mainstream.
Sweet silence.
Look at how we did it, guys.
Oh, my God.
I could buy a...
I could be a duck.
I was like,
I think this is my favorite.
In harmony?
I don't think you can harmonize that.
Nice.
Oh,
it's for this.
Santa's not real.
Okay.
Alright, I gotta go now.
I gotta go.
I had a really fun time with this one.
I told, I said, there was a reason why I never played this.
I wanted to check this out, but I was like, there's no way I
can do it on the main channel.
This game is so short.
I literally finished this game in like 30 minutes.
Santa's not real.
Alright, guys.
I have a member stream tonight.
If you are a member, we're going to be watching Men in
Black.
Thank you all for coming to the announcement and also, uh,
and also coming to staying here for the Twitch stream, the
little after party.
Um, I'm going to go prep.
I'm going to grab some food and then prep for the watchers
on stream.
Uh, it might be like five to ten minutes late only because
I'm going to grab food.
But as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Uh, oh my God.
Oh my gosh.
Pause to check.
Get them around to get that blood flow if you step for me
head to bed cuz you deserve it and remember guys